hello and welcome to the lobby game
spots weekly hangout every tuesday at
2pm pacific right here on gamespot.com
i'm your host daniel dwyer joined by mr
justin haywald how you doing no just you
today buddy just doing good you and me
and the brotherhood of the steel there
this is a little uncomfortable is it it
is you got your notepad i do have
another real andy baumann joint here
like field notes is this some sort of
like it's a chicago made uh notebook
company then they're just really nice i
i like the cover it's like a call of
duty packing you know that's stuff where
they had like the rc car
so this is it is made after or it's
modeled after back in the 50s you had
like traveling salesmen or farmers that
had these kind of pocket notebooks and
this what's what those are based on you
always have i wish we had like a series
of justin haywald's interesting
departures in note collecting because
you
that's a [ __ ] rabbit hole we could go
down over and over again
i i mostly write diary fan fiction in
here oh really yeah could we get into
that is there any fallout fanfiction in
there it's all not safe for work great
and mostly technical well that show's
coming soon check out the fallout 4 show
it's going to be mostly justin haywald's
weird fan fictions
justin you are here
you were here justin because you were
mad he knows a good deal i do and black
friday is coming up which means this is
the time when we celebrate having taken
the country by force and then getting
really good deals on some cool
electronics the problem with black
friday is that it is no longer black
friday it's more like two weeks of
really good deals and it's really really
hard to keep track of
what's an actual good deal because it
was black friday and then cyber monday
sort of spun that off a bit and now
everyone just does whatever well cyber
monday came out we have all these
retailers who are online but now
everybody's online it's not like there's
a physical retail store like there are
some things you can only get in physical
retail but everyone else is like it
makes more sense to do this online
everything's online so first things
first obviously it's a massive part of
holiday
purchasing um i used to work at retail
and like late november was when people
started looking at buying consoles and
that's what i tell everybody to wait
like right now is when you need to have
put off getting your console yes for
sure if you had not bought it back in
the summer like just wait for now
because now you're not only getting the
best deals but the best bundles and and
that's where i think xbox is really
doing well so last month on the npd's in
the us xbox actually outsold the ps4 on
the power of so many bundles and they
have a few more options available now
but you can get a 300 xbox one or a 300
ps4 through almost every store on black
friday because everybody is competing
with one another to have that same price
so it's a deal you can get basically
anywhere and this is if you've been
putting off getting a ps4 xbox one this
is the time to do it you not only get a
300 system but you can get a really good
game with it so 300 dollars for the xbox
one obviously means no connect those are
is there a game builder why would you
want to connect like oh no we i didn't
get connect with this you can trade it
back in
and by by the halo game you know and
it's nice to have the voice controls but
yeah it's not there uh so
do they come with like what bundles are
in terms of like games you know what
games again i saw there was like a tomb
raider one around so the the big one for
playstation is of course uncharted i
think that might be the only one with uh
with xbox there's almost every game that
you can get with that there's a bundle
for tomb raider there's a bundle for
xbox there's a bundle for xbox oh
there's a bundle for two what did i say
tomb raider yeah and uh gears of war
that is basically xbox i think there's
assassin's creed ones flying around
maybe as well perhaps i think the
assassin's creed one you can also get
unity for for free great they need to
get rid of that yeah everyone needs a
needs a coaster uh what about our good
friend the wii u if you've already
purchased the ps4 you've got a sick pc
and you've got an xbox one as well uh
what is there for the the fourth console
for your living room well this is the
console that i think everyone else
should still own like nintendo is a gr
does a great job in making the console
that you own in addition to your primary
gaming console yeah and they do have a
really good black friday deal going on
it's it seems similar in price because
it's 280
and you can get the other systems for
300 but you get two of the best games oh
what games they are super smash brothers
and splatoon oh okay are both relatively
new as well yes relatively new very two
of the best games on the system the only
one that it's missing that is an
absolute must buy is super mario maker
there aren't a lot of good black friday
deals on that one but i think target is
having a buy it for sixty dollars get a
15 gift card so ostensibly fifty dollars
and if you have the gamers club which is
actually a really good deal i usually
don't get into those but it's like
gamers club is gives you a good discount
on those games is that best buy that is
the best bike okay interesting last year
i bought myself a wii u as like my sort
of gift to me
and i had a blast with it especially
because there were so many really great
games that were discounted by the time
that i was picking up and on the second
hand stuff as well and on the nintendo
side there's also the 3ds if for some
reason you've been putting off for the
longest time getting the the only
handheld console remaining there's going
to be some decent black friday deals i
think you can get that for about 180 no
bundles but the new 3ds xl or you know
if you're thinking about upgrading to
the new that's such a dumb name new 3ds
xl the one with the the extra buttons on
it that's a good time to do that as well
do you have any into what amazon are
doing in terms of their stuff because
they often do a lot of like competing
they see the bundles that are out there
in retail or online and other digital
stores they try and reach some sort of
parody there so there's going to be all
of the same deals you're going to be
able to find on amazon as well the thing
that's going to be interesting for
amazon is they always kind of wait till
the last minute to show what their
lightning deals are going to be and what
the prices and what games specifically
those are going to be those go so fast
it's really hard for even us to keep up
with it because they're just constantly
flowing through them and there's so many
but that's you're basically gonna have
to wait till that weekend and friday and
then monday like they just do it for
such a long time amazon's a good place
to keep an eye on i think that for more
individual games that you want to pick
up and there's some really great uh game
deals until dawn like games that came
out this year until dawn for 20 bucks
it's just 20 bucks really 20 bucks at i
want to say best buy amazon has it down
to 30 since this morning so that's
probably a reaction amazon always reacts
to that they they would drop their
prices as well uh bloodborne is another
one you can pick up for 20 bucks wow
it's like game of the year contender
give it to your contender for 20 bucks
and some dlc to add to that so you can
pay a little bit more money as well so
we don't talk about a lot of stuff on
video for the obvious reason that people
want to click links and find out what's
new so for people who want to click
links and find out what's new justin uh
where's the best place on gamespot to
see all this so if you go to the way
that we find everything also on gamespot
because it's hard to find things in our
search bar just go to go to google and
type in gamespot best black friday deals
we have a constantly updated list of
those and if you guys have any deals
that you want to share with us as well
you can drop those into the comments we
are looking for good deals to add in
awesome what are you going to pick up
yourself
nothing you own all the consoles i i own
xbox one ps4 and wii u and 3ds and i've
played almost all of the big games
because i've had to keep up with them
like i'm going to be spending most of my
thanksgiving break trying to catch up on
the games that i just haven't had and
try a chance to do it well our game of
the year discussions are starting next
week so
your discussions are technically
starting now oh yeah that's a fair point
i'm going to pick up until dawn because
i feel like that's one of those sleeper
hits that i sort of haven't spent enough
time with i did some of the uh the beta
stuff or the preview stuff before i came
out and 20 is a great price great price
a great game steam is the other one so
we don't usually get as many good pc
deals right of course newegg is one of
my favorite stores to go to for pc parts
and architecture for pc games there's
not as many good deals steam as is
getting rid of their old model where
they would have uh you know every day
they have a rotating sequence of deals
you have daily deals and it was kind of
silly to keep track of them because
there was only one deal that was good
every day and you would just have to
wait for that deal and they're
completely asking that what they're
doing now is when they do their their
deal when they're going to do their
holiday or their autumn deal it's going
to be for the entire week these are the
prices okay this is our lowest price you
don't have to wait for a deal to come up
so that for if you want to get up a pc
game as soon as steam releases all of
their deals that's a good man clockwork
tales of ink glass and ink for the yet
right there 250 pick it up while it's
hot yeah let's see the trailer
those hot bangers that artifacts
didn't see what the rest of that was
man i love steam it's that [ __ ] bird
do you call them bangers isn't that like
a sausage hot bangers yeah sure that's a
regional thing the hot sausages games
can be hot bangers too look at this see
these graphics like 404 it's dope look
at that all those games and more highly
positive 316 reviews there came out two
years ago but it still got those hot
next-gen graphics look at that girl
she's so happy also pc exclusive pc
exclusive because who else would want it
clockwork tails the glass
of glass and ink that looks all right
there you go p steam it's got a whole
other thing going on while we're all
talking about gaming ears they've still
got all this stuff
crazy madness uh justin haywald thank
you so much for coming on thank you
telling me how to save some money uh let
me know folks in the comment box below
what do you think of the deals is there
any console you haven't picked up yet
we're kind of deep into this console
generation now so surely you've already
got your primary choice maybe you're
looking at picking up a secondary one
what is it let us know in the comments
below uh we have a bunch of sections on
today which means we've got a bunch of
trailers in this first one i can't wait
for apparently arkham knight got an
update i thought that update was the pc
version finally working but they've
decided to put a trailer for it so let's
check that out
can't let him see here
face it robin
you're half the man he was
what's a nintendo video game console
without a bunch of weird sports games
we've got another one mario tennis is
back it's scott butterworth hello is it
good
not really great
that's pretty much the internet
like my i really wanted my review to
just be a gif of me going it's fine yeah
like that really could have been the
review because
it's
these games
seem to fall into two camps the
oh it's as mediocre as you might expect
to this is a surprisingly good one like
mario striker's charge this is a
surprisingly good one yeah like what was
the mario the tennis game on gamecube
that was one i really yeah it was like
and the one on 64 as well the first uh
mario tennis on 64. excellent like i
played a lot of that actually i played a
lot of goldeneye and then would
alternate over to mario tennis when we
needed a palette cleanser so there's a
lot of those too both of which were
incredibly frustrating to play with your
friends who are better than you though
so i i don't recommend building
friendships on either of those games so
mario tennis ultra smash that's true
ultra smash it's better as they get was
that the remember they did that whole ds
thing where like it was like every game
had like a ds subtitle was the ultra for
the wii u is that what they were doing
uh not that i'm aware of i mean maybe
you've stumbled onto a really
fascinating naming trends that none of
us notice we're reading between the
lines but look this looks rad what's
wrong with you scott look mario is huge
it actually does it looks like pretty
good yeah i mean it's it's a very pretty
game and it's got those like you know
flashy trails behind the ball when you
hit it a certain way you can play two
this is a two-player game it's like i
will say that being able to use the uh
the the uh player the gamepad as a
second screen makes local multiplayer a
lot more fun because you can uh just
have yeah you have the camera angle
exactly how you want it you kind of want
the camera behind your avatar when
you're playing and so this allows two
players to have that so local
multiplayers
in a way benefits from that pretty
substantially even though they don't use
the gamepad in any like more creative
ways beyond that it's still nice to have
that a lot of games haven't been doing
that even from nintendo the the wii u
gamepad is basically reverted to being a
second screen and so many games i think
have just shifted over to that instead
of trying to make this do something new
new or unique or original
here's a way for you to play this game
and let somebody else use the tv because
they probably don't want to watch you
play this game yeah i've been playing
mario maker all weekend and i'm really
enjoying that sort of whole experience
yeah you're saying a lot of nice things
about this mario tennis game
why does it only get six out of ten so
loses a lot of points simply because
it's it's a very empty game it's just
very bare bones like the least amount of
stuff you could put in a game like okay
we're done here you go it's like there's
no tournament mode there's no real like
campaign or career or anything oh wow uh
yeah there's nothing really to like work
towards there's no progression of any
kind like you can unlock there are a
handful of weird like cartoony courts
that you can unlock and they're like
kind of fun but it's like really not
much to work towards so the biggest
issue is just the game is really empty
it was like nothing like the older games
like the gamecube game had you know
these wild minigames that used the
mechanics in sort of interesting ways
and
all the characters had different power
shots that were unique to those
characters so depending on who you were
playing it would change the experience
in some way but there's nothing that
meaningfully meaningfully changes the
mechanics of this game it's just like
yeah you can hit a ball back and forth a
bunch playing tennis woo and like that's
fun yoshi's lucky
like the biggest thing that added this
time was mega battle which is basically
a quick play mode in which a little toad
so you can see hanging on the side of
court there will toss mega mushrooms at
you and your character will like grow to
supersize for a brief period of time but
if both characters are supersized then
like it's almost impossible to miss
because you're so big you have like
infinite reach so it just turns into
like a meaningless volley for a minute
as you wait for the other person to
shrink and then if you shrink it the
wrong title you don't have any control
over when you shrink back down to your
regular size and if the ball happens to
be coming towards you when you shrink
you'll probably just miss it and you'll
lose a point simply because of just poor
luck i mean it doesn't indicate that
it's about to happen but even if you
knew sometimes the timing works out that
you couldn't do anything about it anyway
and you're just oh you shrank and the
ball went past you because you're
suddenly like have way less reach and
you just get screwed by the game it's
like how did no one think of this so you
can add amiibo look at all the amiibos
yeah even the amiibo functionality is
like kind of bare bones like you can
bring them along with you in like the
closest thing to a campaign that this
game has which is like a ladder style
playing every character in a row
increasingly difficult and you can drag
an amiibo character along with you for
that and you can actually bring it
online they just sit on the baseline
yeah they kind of hang out on the
baseline like anything you miss they
might pick up although i experimented
with it to see exactly how much help
they would give you and basically if you
return the serve and then just run away
they will pretty much take care of
things foreign kind of hilarious they
level up faster if you make them do that
i don't know but you can't level them uh
which is important like if you're really
into amiibos you can actually level them
up by playing um the the latter mode and
you can bring them online as well so you
have a little like extra help like your
amiibo buddy online is better as a
result of that training although
anything that you do with amiibo can
only be saved to that one game like if
you want to use that amiibo then in
super smash brothers you have to delete
all of that data you can't carry it over
between games that's the way the way
amiibo works delete the data yes it
won't even just like leave it there no
it'll just no you lose that data
that's deleted from your character you
have to move it over not only is your
daisy no good at tennis in smash bros
but she's also no good at tennis in
tennis game anymore yeah amiibo still
hasn't found that hook that makes it a
really good game and that has because it
sold millions
who's buying all these amiibos all right
good question justin who is who's buying
we demand answers i only have like 40.
i was really disappointed i tried other
nintendo characters hoping that there
would be like secret character unlocks
no like it's only the characters that
are in the game so it's like warriors in
the game if you have a wario amiibo
that'll work that's like link link
amiibo didn't work oh really nope but
don't you unlock like slightly more
sparkly gold versions of all the
characters yeah like you eventually like
when you beat the ladder mode you unlock
like the star version of that character
and like a little star icon on the menu
but
i couldn't actually figure out how that
impacted like what it did
like i would assume that it makes the
character like better
but i don't know what that means and
like it didn't have a tangible impact on
the gameplay they didn't really look
different they didn't really play
different so it's like why did i bother
grinding all the way through this like
ladder match mode
to like well you're now you're doing a
tennis you're a tennis player you're a
tennis pro
yeah
so i think one hour didn't feel worth it
i think it's a problem for
nintendo's for what people think of the
wii u that these kind of games are
coming out late in the year because
they've had a really good year sure and
now we're having these kind of
lackluster final titles uh animal
crossing amiibo festival this and just
from nintendo in general triforce heroes
games that kind of feel half-baked like
they're good they're mechanically solid
they look good they sound good but
there's a lot missing and it feels like
maybe they're rushed out
and i think part of that might be
because we're gonna see the nx next year
because i for for the longest time i've
been thinking like they're going to
announce it next year it'll come out
even later
this feels like they're gearing up to
announce and ship the nx next year
because these games they're just pushing
these out it's got all the wacky sports
titles out there especially when you
look at like how much they put into
amiibo and then you have such limited
functionality for all of these games
like it feels like if they were really
trying to push something with this and
games that are just missing it entirely
like triforce heroes if they were really
something behind these if they needed
them to incubate longer they would have
put all that functionality into it and i
think they're just getting rid of these
titles now to shift over uh last
question for you scott the
the game seems shallow it seems
enjoyable in some respect though it's
still got a six out of ten on gamespot
yeah is this something you might
consider
you know recommending people pick up if
it hits like thirty dollars something
like that i mean
it's up to you how much you wanna spend
on games right i mean for certain people
thirty dollars is still a lot of money
for something sixty dollars isn't a lot
of money or fifty dollars um so i mean
it just depends yeah i mean it did get a
six the six is a fair
score you know it doesn't mean the game
is bad it just means that it could have
been
quite a bit better yeah um and the thing
that really saved for me is that the
local multiplayer is pretty fun i mean
it is a competently executed tennis game
with like the fun colors of a mario
sports game you know so if you have
people that you like to have over to
your house to sit down and play games
especially like kind of light fun party
games they're easy to pick up and kind
of competitive but not too you know
crazy or in-depth uh this is a fun one
to pick up for for that kind of
circumstance anything else probably not
so much but if you're that kind of
person and that kind of gamer this could
totally be something that you'll have
some fun with what if you're like me and
you live alone and live sadly and just
sit around and play games in your
underwear while eating cookie dough
that's what like league of legends is
for man
all right let's go just kidding just
kidding guys just kidding it's uh yeah
all the lol fans just go out and you're
lucky travis gafford was here yesterday
would have taken oh yeah there's several
people who would punch me in the face
for saying that i'm glad none of them
are on this couch justin thanks for
coming on thank you
scott as ever thank you for your review
if you want to read the full review it's
up on gamespot.com 6 out of 10 is the
score but make sure you go over there
check the written review or was there a
video review we did a woman there was
not there's a one minute review on
facebook okay so there is so you have to
read actual words to get to read actual
words
you gotta work for it uh let us know
what you think of uh of the latest uh
mario tennis game if you play to
yourself ultra smash ultra smash smash
uh in the comment box below uh our good
friends over at cd projekt they made a
pretty good game this year uh with your
three and some pretty great reviews for
that this year they also put out a nice
uh expansion pack that's done a little
bit well uh but then they've decided
just to put out this trailer they
basically tooting their own horn
have you seen this yeah you know who's
it you know who's a good developer you
know what a good game is check this one
out witcher we made that it's this
it looked like a little bit like they
made this trailer just to remind
everyone well game of the year is about
to kick off that hey we came out five
months ago i remember now it was a bad
idea it's super easy to forget about
this early and especially now that yeah
february has sort of become like the new
holiday season or it's like oh it didn't
fit holiday season we're going to
release in february but then by the time
game of the year rolls around it's like
hey remember us so if you think about it
in those terms it actually makes a lot
of sense
i don't know it could be a game of
thrones but uh yeah yeah it could be
we're all our game of the year
discussions are going to start off or
they haven't started i guess oh yeah
we're going to be getting in a room next
week real soon but until then here is a
trailer made by cna project which is
called i think it's called an epic year
for the witcher 3.
all right let's check it out
oh
so
[ __ ]
the xbox 360 is 10 years old 10 years
gentlemen
10. count them
look at him i am also 10.
justin are you 10
no god howard are you 10 i am 10
multiplied nice it's uh it's been a good
uh good long period of time they're
still making games for it gta 5 came out
yeah titanfall tomb raider this has kind
of been the last year for the the xbox
360. this is kind of when we've seen the
transition where we're not getting more
uh xbox 360 ps3 games everything is
getting canceled for that in favor of
xbox one of course now you've got that
hot backwards compatibility so you're
gonna be able to resell and bundle all
360 games with every remake and uh
i think that's really kick people in the
nuts who are working on hd like the guys
who did casual crash castle crashers hd
they had no idea backwards compatibility
was coming yeah and they were like oh
[ __ ] you guys yeah it's like the meat
boy just came out on ps4 and everything
and it's like oh my god yeah i only get
like fifa for like years to come right i
mean that's always like the the last few
years are just like here's like nine
more sports games like legacy edition or
i think
even i want to say this year's games
might have been branded legacy edition
oh maybe call of duty did the thing or
where they stripped out the campaign as
well right it usually seems to be the
big triple h games and then sports ones
because they're not allowed to call them
shitty edition
yeah
yeah
well they are but
anyway
the campaign we're not like you know
it's fine and you know a version without
it you're not missing i was gonna play
it for game of the year stuff but
maybe not maybe not maybe i'm right but
you're probably okay
let's not talk about the sort of the the
gray years of the console let's talk
about its wonderful youthful prime uh so
what were some of the best red ringing
left and right
yeah the early days of 360. how many did
you go through how many three original
three i only had two die uh i had my
first elite my launch 360 still works
because i bought an elite and stopped
using it before the first one could
break did you have any doubt um uh i had
one i was pretty lucky i think i had one
red ring which i managed to uh wrap the
towel round and nurse it back into
temporary health until it finally gave
up the ghost bit now i think i was
pretty lucky because i only went through
one until i moved on to an elite so i
also only went through one uh in fact
they fixed that one and sent it back to
me but now because it's a pal one and
i moved over here and like none of the
games would work so i had to bring it
with me but it's like i had to take off
the faceplate and stuff because the disk
drive is so broken like the wedge and
knife in every time i take the disc out
so now it just looks like it's we have a
room out the back which is you know
filled with the the the the carcasses
there is some kind of game spot
repository of like dead xbox 360. they
don't want them anymore we asked micro
when i was at one up we were like
getting rid of these consoles was like
hey do you want to take our old original
xbox ones and 360. like no
xbox ones
xbox original original no
like we have two we have two red ring
debugs over there so it's just like and
no one wants those they're just like
they're useless so yeah madness anyway
not talking about breaking hardware or
old-ass fifa games coming out on all
consoles um the best games came out on
xbox 360. when i say that jeff what's
the first game of pumps in there it's
burnout paradise i mean obviously like
you know you know you don't bring me on
here to not talk about burnout paradise
soccer is compatible as well no it does
not oh it's not something that they said
was coming but i don't think was part of
that initial wave um so unless they've
added it past that initial wave i don't
believe it's there yet um in a weird way
that game is doing stuff now that or did
stuff then which racing games now are
basically hanging their sort of coats on
it's well yeah yeah i think so and you
know there was a the i want to say
it was the most wanted not the not the
original 2005-2006 one but the
criteria the criterion most wanted was
basically a burnout game in the way in
terms of the way its multiplayer was
structured it's actually one of the sad
things about where need for speed has
been at this past couple years is
like it's just they they lost it they
had it and they lost it they had it all
figured out
they nailed it
and then now i've gotten so far away
from nailing it uh that yeah that's uh
it's a great driving game well they own
the rights to burning as well so yeah
shall we see maybe a resurgence it's
it's one of these games that was super
popular with critics didn't sell an
absolute bunch load well yeah it's one
of those things where it's like just
the virtue of writing need for speed on
the box makes it sell more copies than
burnout right just because it's a more
established brand that's why you know
criterion took over a need for speed and
then they split off to do ghost games
and also there's like there's burnout
lineage all over need for speed now it's
just the wrong parts of the lineage are
making its way in now but uh yeah i
think that's a fantastic game um
gosh i mean you know halo's golden years
took place on the xbox halo 3 you know
wonderful three is a terrific game uh
you know reach is a good game odst is a
lot of fun you know like kind of the
those were those if i had to pick three
halo games those are the three right
um
you know gears i think was pretty
transformative gears was a huge one yeah
for me what drove with me i was a pc
gamer up to that point yeah and or
primarily a pc gamer and you know a lot
of my time in terms of multiplayer which
drove a lot of my game time was was
uh was was playing uh you know early
call of duty it was playing um day of
defeat you know counter-strike uh in the
office on a lan with friends and it was
live which changed
live which brought me over the console
primarily and
and gears was a big part of that
uh modern warfare was a big part of that
but um it was primarily the the left for
dead games i mean those right those
games when we when i joined gamespot
cnet back in 2006 in the uk
you know soon after that those were
those were the the years when everyone
in the office would get together as a
social gathering online on friday night
and play left a day yeah there was it
was like gears was one of those as well
like event games where it seemed like
everyone was buying them so that they
could all play with each other and i
think you know the social aspect of
multiplayer gaming was before that for
me was driven by physically being with
people in an office on a lan
when i played online and i played a fair
bit online it would be against randoms
yeah all of a sudden being able to bring
your group of friends together and play
online make a day when you all got home
on friday night to get pizza in and and
use live that that that transformed it
for me at least and i mean left or dead
one and two those games are pretty
impeccable yeah and like a sort of a
crazy i don't know showing of just how
far multiplayer games have come on
consoles where you had a game like left
4 dead which involved so much
cooperation that you know people had
sort of gotten used to playing with each
other so much
it seems like that was better than it is
now like i don't feel like the xbox one
or ps4 like playing with
parties great co-op experiences yeah
well yeah they aren't the great co-op
experiences aren't always happening and
then i mean you know the the party stuff
on xbox one was so mangled and still you
know
they've made improvements but i feel
like it's not maybe not where it needs
to be and also i think you know maybe
we've changed or i think that people
have changed to a certain extent we're
like you know i i used to feel okay
about wearing a headset while just
playing a game you know with random
people and stuff like that like played a
lot of call of duty 4. like that was you
know another huge huge huge xbox 360
game for me
um
and was a little more willing to just
kind of even just hear what people had
to say
and now it's just like wait i don't want
to hear anything i i do not wear a
headset unless i'm playing the only time
i ever wear a headset now for for
multiplayer or any form of gaming is
when i'm in a private party with friends
i mean that's it i mean i don't play
with random yeah and now it's like you
hear voices coming at your tv it sounds
you know because it wasn't coming that
was like something that was like super
ubiquitous during the xbox 360
man yeah it was like now it's like a
nuisance you're just like what is this
idiot like he's not even he's talking to
someone else or like worse nowadays
they're running a live stream yeah and
they've they've left their chat on to
the game so you're listening to them
commentate their own game as they're
playing it you're just like shut the
[ __ ] up what happened to the days of
watching guys doing cocaine while
playing uno that was that was maybe if i
had to pick one moment for xbox live it
was the night i tuned in and saw xbox
live vision cameras and like people just
straight up canadians doing lines while
playing you need to tune into
playstation
live or whatever that thing is some
weird stuff happens
is that still going strong like strong
that's the legacy might not be the right
yeah
very very strong there's a section of
society that's drawn to it so xbox live
i think changed things but it was also
the achievement points like that was the
only time in my life when i cared about
these and was working at oneup.com and
egm and we had active competitions to
see who could get the most achievement
points and you're just playing all these
shitty games like avatar things that are
gonna be like how quickly can i get a
thousand points for this and how how
many points did you guys get over there
see i i was never as high as shoe like
sh shu was our de facto he was the
danchu editor-in-chief of egym at the
time
i'm on i'm up 40 000 now forty six but i
was a forty i have two accounts so i i
have twenty five on my old uk account
before i moved to the us but at some
point i dropped off but that was
actually what you're gonna write your
digital dick though
well mine is now 150 well i was gonna
say if you're gonna speak to anyone
about achievements because i remember
watching this man through the uk so i
was like we ran videos on the site about
how to usually get achieved nba 2k6 yeah
like all those early games but that was
you know that was like that era of game
spot it was like you know me and carrie
guscos and
a few other people on staff like were
got super into that stuff like carrie
and i bought japanese 360s so that we
could buy japanese games to get points
and within school it was like the with
friends who i who never owned the
microsoft console never didn't touch the
original xbox and suddenly we were all
just like going at it at achievements
and like passing it like in college and
passing games around being like oh you
want this one it's like an easy 1 000.
yeah it was crazy i just made me feel
really old danny thanks yeah i'm sorry
but you had to say college because i saw
you recall when i said school but it's
like they still exist but i just don't
care i mean the playstation introduced
trophies like okay yeah
that stuff came in too late you know you
know if you you had to pick one number
pretty early on on that one and it was
like okay you're adding trophies
mid-stream on the ps3 like whatever uh
and and now that you know steam
achievements have never meant anything
and yeah you know and they never hit
reset on xbox one so he never felt like
he wanted to get back
and also just you know i think things
got muddied in terms of like where the
lead platform was and and where third
parties were were kind of putting their
efforts and stuff like that like you
know sony's you know the
the market leader right now which i
think changes a lot of things for that
stuff as well so yeah
but for me it was just struck strictly
like
no one
was interested in keeping up anymore it
was just like okay well i'm done with
this this is insane why am i doing this
why am i doing this oh god why am i
doing this
the only reiner andrew reiner game
informer was is i think he is higher
than i am the leader he was one of the
yeah well and part of it was like crazy
it was this thing that it introduced in
the games that made me want to dive into
them deeper it's like if it's a game
that i love i i just want to get the
most out of it like assassin's creed 2
is i think the last game that i did
absolutely everything maybe maybe it was
bioshock was it was before that but it's
like oh well i just want to get all 1000
achievement points everything for the
dlc what's everything that i can get out
of this game it was like proving to
myself that i have milked it for
everything yeah it was a super
interesting like barometer of how much
of a game you'd completed outside of the
sort of the big aaa stuff though also on
the xbox 360 we saw the sort of rise of
independent development hitting console
well actually probably just across the
board like the real big rise of the
indies but especially being able to play
indie games on consoles and games that
went on to sell millions xbox live
arcade was just an amazing platform for
these really tiny games that i mean we
mentioned uno but braid and castle
crashers like bringing the behemoth to
prominence was was because of xbla there
was i mean this the summer of arcade was
was a real highlight of every year while
that was running and i um i mean
one of my favorite games on on on the
entire
years of 360s is shadow complex right i
mean it's like still still waiting for
that sequel right but but
you know there were there were real
highlights that came through the live
program and that did change the
landscape because sony was way behind on
that yeah for sure totally and then you
know it was one of those things that
like it seems insane now that they
limited it to like one game a week right
uh but nowadays you know it's like tons
of those games tons of download only
games are coming out and ps4 and xbox
one and like there's no fanfare just
like stuff just appears and you're like
oh is that i didn't realize that stuff
i've never heard of just appears on
playstation
no marketing you know it's just there's
there's no yeah it's just stuff just
shows up out of i don't know where it is
it seems special it almost felt like
triple a games just like but like sort
of cheaper little
like me when meat boy came out remember
everyone was like waiting for super meat
to come out that morning but then you
know there were definitely weeks where
like the game was awful and you were
like man this sucks yeah put out more
than one game like i think there was
there was a double edge to that and it
was it's a little bit behind the scenes
but back then we also had access to all
of those games for free like as things
weren't downloaded or as things were put
onto the system we had our debug units
would let us just download and play them
play these and try them out which we
don't have now with xbox one and ps4 but
it was like a way to try these out and
see like well what's worth it and just
having immediate access to everything or
stuff before it came out that stuff was
really spotty because there were games
that showed up there that never shipped
yeah oh wow like someone was working on
an rbi baseball years and years ago and
at one point that showed up and was
playable and it was like okay is this
ever going to get announced to come out
turns out no
never gotten officially announced it
came out like you know word of it kind
of got out you know there's supposed to
be an nda in place to talk about stuff
that appears on partner and i feel like
enough years have maybe passed that it's
maybe okay now but uh but yeah like
stuff like that would happen there was
that saints row downloadable game that
was like the guide the bullet thing that
showed up there i don't think that ever
came out
uh yeah that stuff was was cool and then
i guess in terms of the increased power
that we saw on those consoles coming out
of the previous generation with the
original xbox and playstation 2. uh you
know just cause three is then next week
and we saw the sort of the rise of the
open world game where like you know gta
3 had obviously done really well on ps2
and had its own trilogy but in the time
the xbox 360 was out we got grand theft
auto 4 we got you know red dead
redemption uh well elder scrolls
oblivion one of the early games was i
mean that was a real it's funny you know
obviously
you guys chatting about fallout last
week in terms of some of the the
technical issues with that game
but at that time elder scrolls oblivion
was that was the cutting edge and i
remember seeing the initial screens and
then seeing what that was doing running
on on that new console which was only a
year in at the time actually very early
um and it was
it was astonishing like and it came out
at a time that people were starved for
something unique on that console you
know so like that came out and people
were like okay you know unless they had
played moral wind on the original xbox
or something they'd never seen anything
like that it's just like there were
people buying that game who would never
touch a fantasy game yeah i mean that
game made obviously like made bethesda
yeah you know uh it was in the right
place at the right time and it was it
was a just a great great game and it
introduced us to microtransactions with
horse armor right yeah so many great
firsts exactly in the xbox 360. right
okay let's uh before we wrap this up uh
if you had to pick one we're coming into
game of the year territory which is the
horrible sophie's choice of trying to
figure out what the best game is in a
catalog of wonderful games so going down
the couch if you had to pick one game
out of the xbox 360 that would be your
favorite uh jeff first of all it would
be
oh man i i i'm gonna probably stick with
with burnout paradise for the 360. uh
rock band probably one of the run of the
rock band games probably comes close
that whole thing happens as well yeah
yeah justin what about yourself it's
probably the coke but i guess uno
that counts like castle crushes i have
so many fond memories of just like
sitting with friends on the couch
and just plowing through that game like
i loved castle crashers excellent ben uh
well best experience left it to just
fond memories but probably the best game
red dead redemption yeah i mean
to me that's still rockstar's best game
um last time we gave a game of the year
as well yeah 2010.
all right it was around the end of the
it was 20 concerts
tremendous game people can't wait for a
sequel yeah
let me tell you about bully though if
we're going to talk about
best games
yes
you may know it as that's all right i
guess that actually that did come to
360. the best game that came out 360 was
john moos stranglehold anyways oh man
table tennis right
yeah table
oh man like that was though as someone
who was colorblind that game was a huge
bummer because it was all about the
color the ball the spin on the ball was
represented by a color and they had no
options for like sure that was one of
the first things my wife would literally
kind of like it's so realistic yeah
this is the future of gaming technology
this is it this black room with jesper
looking at you angry
excellent uh gentlemen thanks for coming
on uh ben justin and jeff appreciate it
let us know what you think of the xbox
360 10 years later are you ready to pick
one up uh what's your favorite game that
came out during uh now's the time i know
right yeah it's super cheap and it
probably won't break and if it does you
won't get a replacement uh yeah what's
your favorite game on the xbox 360. let
us know in the comment box below
all right gents i've got two more
sections i think on today's show we're
talking about a bunch of stuff
apparently there's a trailer for new
moves in wwe 2k16 do you know about this
there are no new moves
not able to work that out unfortunately
i mean you were in a trailer for this
game so you should go watch the trailer
no i don't know what you're talking
about go watch the trailer where do you
see it
let's uh let's check out the new moves
for wwe 2k16.
so
just as good as those one dudes yeah
yeah weird pentatonix pentatonix did you
see that they did like a
oh audio thing and they had an orchestra
back them up it was like some american
markets or backed them up yeah but all
they were doing was go
and then one guy didn't ridiculously
high so oh my gosh i thought meme video
got two billion views oh did it have
text on it though probably star wars
it's hot you may have seen it on
gamespot.com or anywhere else on the
internet we've got three star wars
experts here rob the woodsman handlery
josh layers shaw and andy nasa nasa
bowman
gentlemen are you excited
for what battlefront for the movie
not battlefront who's still playing
battlefront
playing a little bit of it yeah yeah
kind of wears off right yeah we knew
that yeah
we knew that going in well you know i'm
away from the dlc uh but i enjoyed
battlefront a lot i mean it's a star
wars game it's the best sounding looking
star wars game i feel like ow
right now
is it the best star wars it's got like
the most graphics i'll give you that the
most graphics it's got 1080p it's got
plenty of graphics it's got lots of
frames per second it's a lot of graphics
yeah but is it the best star wars game
no no no no no not by a long shot then
let's go down through it uh andy bauman
yeah first of all uh that title belongs
to the
classic rebel assault and rebel assault
ii oh really a nice little fmv driven
game on the bbc back in the day not
expecting this to be the first one
we did not talk about i'm just kidding
this well if we're going off like you
know at the time these graphics were
insane because it was video you can't
get better than video right yeah but did
people think about that
battlefront hasn't stopped that let's go
back as far as we can then let's think
about that swing versus typhoon yeah
let's get into like when the really good
ones start coming that's that's got to
be like 1992-93 x-wing okay let's find
out so x-wing tie fighter then x-wing
versus tie fighter that whole series was
just incredible because what it gave you
was a simulation experience of a type
fighter pilot an x-wing pilot you you do
the shields you link your blasters you
do your power your engines you freaking
fly around and shoot dudes like
and not even the flying in battlefront
is as good as this like this is the best
flying so like you you you would compare
it again
it's one of the best
uh space simulator flying games ever and
you see uh
this hud maybe makes no sense but like
you have your shields there on the
bottom left you can decide if you want
full front full back uh you can link
your lasers there you can see in the
targeting reticle there are linked fire
so all four fire at once or you can do a
succession fire uh you have torpedoes
you have you do these epic dog fights
where you're chasing down yeah like
fighting in 3d is really hard to do
right yeah yeah and especially
yeah but yeah and back then when it was
on 11
uh floppy disks like this was
really freaking and let's speak to that
with the next games right because these
games were definitely like they felt
like they were ahead of the time when
they came out and when dark forces came
out in the mid 90s that also felt like
oh wow wait we're this is like a first
person
star wars game where i feel like like
i'm shooting storm troopers i'm walking
around these environments and obviously
this series ended up you know your dark
forces too jedi knight and which then
spawned the sort of later jedi academy
uh jedi outcast sort of stuff but yeah
these are all games uh any of you guys
play these ones oh what play the crap
out of these games because
uh when my dad went to the software
store the guy was like you want to buy
this it's like doom
but better
because it is like it's exact it's it's
the same style but like you shoot storm
troopers with the blaster guns like from
the movies like it's insane like how as
a kid you played this and you were like
instantly drawn into this so so much and
like there's so many knots in the movies
there's thermal detonators there's crazy
swamp monsters you have to fight they're
really hard there's like every
stormtrooper every imperial and there's
like mon mothman you're like working for
like there's so much good stuff in these
games
and they're really hard as well yes like
not easy it's no joke and
they were so much more varied than doom
at the time like doom was like go here
push the exit you're done these like had
missions and stuff yeah well like back
then three years in you know first
person design was like a lifetime you
know yeah this was like 1995 and then i
think it was 99 when uh dark forces two
jedi knight came out and then we had a
resurgence with the you know the kyle
katarin uh jedi outcast jedi academy
games and those incredible teams which
it's even hard to remember that they
were sort of rebirths of those old ones
because those games were so brilliant on
their own right like third person
land land party dead party jedi fights
yeah you're kidding me like when they
know i'm even a star wars fan i used to
love that [ __ ] when they introduced the
lightsaber into those games you were
like how's this gonna work oh my god
they nailed it yeah like it's perfect
and you throw it like you have all the
powers you push you throw it you like in
you know in battlefield when you become
uh yeah the hero or whatever and you're
like luke and you push attack and you
like
you have no control like you're just
lunging forward with your lightsaber
these you had like epic control you jump
you do flips you like nail stuff you
throw it and you have duels with other
like it was so
[ __ ] good like like at a lamb party
there was nothing better than doing
things and like you someone would fire a
rocket and you're just like force push
it back and i'm like nope really like
the fact that was in those games back
then was like incredible and now in
battlefront you play as
like
you play as luke invader and it's you
just feel dumb right like you feel so
dumb it's like just two toys like
yeah yeah
uh josh when you think about good star
wars games what do you think of uh well
there was a shadow of the empire right
that's what it's called i always forget
the name the n60 phone though oh yeah i
remember like the morning i got the n64
me and my dad like spent hours trying to
figure out how to beat the first level
to take out the atv uh atat because i
didn't know about the tow cable because
it's the first time i've ever held an
n64 controller and everything and what
the [ __ ] is this thing
yeah
wait i don't hold which
which handles do i use which part goes
in my mouth
don't wait this is what we were actually
saying
well oh that's okay actually
legitimately that's what we were saying
is that this game had the most bizarre
cheat code oh really ever created and my
parents thought i was mentally ill when
i was doing it because what you had to
do was hold down every single button on
the 64 controller for how long
uh you had to hold it all down all in
order right you had to like do it and
press them in an order i don't remember
that sounds like some like the urban
myth
that was not yeah no but whoever did it
was like let's just make people look as
dumb as possible and then you had to uh
basically move the stick halfway to the
left halfway to the right
to the left halfway right like four
times so at this point you're like
either your brother had to do it which
is what i made my brother do you think
he was in a lot of places
yeah so or i would do this or i would
take the controller and i would put it
in my mouth and use my lip as a halfway
guard
and do this
and do this
four or five times then
and someone would come in the room be
like what the hell are you doing are you
fellating that again i want to be a
whopper
which was like so you could just
you know is the guy that beats up luke
and empire strikes back it's a big like
furry white uh bear cool you could be as
him you could spawn them or just be as
play as one but the whole thing was then
in the end you could play as million
falcon
tie fighter you get all these cool
things uh but that was a that was like
what was so sick about that game is
there's so many modes like it starts out
flying a ship and then it goes first
person shooter rice and then it goes
there's like turret modes when you're
riding in a ship the outrider
um yeah like good variety yeah speaking
of nintendo consoles did any of you guys
play the star wars or super star wars
games on the nes no i didn't have
anything else a lot of people are going
to talk about that as well let us know
in the comments
yeah actually just came out on ps4 it's
all those the whole time
we played at a friend's house cool but
that game was right too can you buy
those separately from
from the front
from battlefront yeah no i'm not sure oh
did it just come out
separate it was always like its own
thing it's like four games or something
like that it's a package i'm not sure
how much things like ten bucks i don't
know uh anyone here played republic
commando
no goddamn
this was the first person
like it was basically like halo odst oh
yeah but with boba fett
i guess they're not really stormtroopers
they're like republican so they're kind
of like the next layer right it was like
a four player oh jesus here's a video i
made years ago oh yeah um
like
uh
you and three other like people you know
what the [ __ ]
and the coolest thing was if you killed
somebody up front you'd get blood on
your visor and it would [ __ ] clean
like a laser would just go like
wow
the [ __ ] blood
yeah
i don't usually play the game killing
every single stormtrooper in it but yeah
see look what's with the blood
that is cool
extremely distracting
yes
that game is all right cool
and i guess one of the biggest pc games
you want to talk about star wars pc
games though uh night city republic andy
you played a bunch of that oh well that
was like
the best game i played like i'm sure if
i go back to it now i'll see through a
lot of it but back then dude not only
was it this sprawling rpg with like
amazing decisions yeah a great plot
twist yeah uh
but it was like the precursor to mass
effect because you're traveling the
galaxy on this ship you have companions
basically talking to all them doing
quests for them uh going to all these
different locations doing like quests on
those locations like it was so epic and
it was all in it was like star wars
right it was totally star wars yeah
lightsaber the combat system was like a
little bit weird because it was like
straight up rpg you had to like yeah cue
up stuff and cue up moves and but it was
cool um
but yeah it was like basically mass
effect before they decided to just make
their own universe and this was set like
it was like in some it was like before
yeah super before any of the like star
wars stuff right so you kind of felt
like yeah you could you know greg
katzman liked it too it wasn't like
you're rubbing shoulders with [ __ ]
you know film actors and knowing that
you could have that much effect over the
world like you didn't know what was
gonna happen yeah that's another big
thing that turned me off about
battlefront is like you have all the
main heroes doing it well like uh shadow
of the empire you were like han solo's
friend he was basically his twin but
like you're like daddy's rendering with
your own smugglership and your own
chewbacca yeah
it's funny i actually just just skimmed
through shadows of the empire because i
forgot like what was actually a story
about and it's so cool
it's funny how they just like took just
plot elements you know what i mean of
the movies and then just kind of filled
in the gap like oh really there's this
dash vendor guy who's just you know he's
hanging out with luke and leia like he's
part of the gang am i right in saying
that literally every game we've talked
about today has been stripped out of the
star wars lore
yes yeah i mean everything has
once like disney bottom the only things
that remain canon are like all the
movies and those kids cartoon series
wait even the three even the lucas's the
prequels are pringles those are canon
yeah yeah
so it's those six movies and then like
everything they make now so any new book
or any new comic or any new clone wars
the show or whether with rebels so
kolkataran doesn't exist in star wars
anymore oh that's depressing like the
republic commanders don't wipe blood off
their faces they did something kind of
cute where they call them legends so now
it's almost like in this universe it's
kind of like
a little bit of like maybe their stories
people tell each other or something
rather than actual history the stories
are they're true remember how kotor
basically like legitimize going light
and dark side because it was rpg you
choose like oh yeah like paragon
renegade people kind of yeah
like oh it's there's no gray area but
it's like in that one it was like dark
so i'd like something all right i
totally made that i think i know your
answer then let's go through everyone
what's your favorite star wars game ever
made rebels
that's really probably one or two
i never played two it came out like a
year later yeah didn't it yeah and i i
just heard the ending was god-awful and
everything was terrible all right but i
guess it was okay josh shaw uh rogue
squadron on gamecube oh okay all right
thank you
yeah i like because you have the b wing
in that one and there's like this like
shield that would come down the
highlight enemy shifts i don't know it
just felt like you're really like in
control of one of those things
little buttons and stuff god the best
thing about i just want a gamecube so i
can just put a disc in remember how good
that
is tiny little hole in the middle he's
going
done it was like mini discs felt good
and it had a handle you could just pick
it like you pick it up again
remember because like the whole reason
to get a ps2 is also dvd you couldn't
fit a dvd in
it uh rob handler favorite star wars
video game rogue squadron 64. okay
and it's funny you were mentioning like
tie fighter and x-wing and all those
yeah like and where i think this movie
is getting me really excited was because
i did read a bunch of books growing up
but that game
worked me so well as a kid and made me
so excited because it was like x-wings
and ships in atmospheric landscapes oh
right right so when you see the trailer
for the first time and it's an x-wing
booking across the water causing the
water to steam up and ripple it's like
you know you just get rogue squads and
it's like oh yeah
yeah you have wedge antilles and tillies
these guiding you through yeah he had
these like background characters that
were so sick like and there was uh
luke's co-pilot like dak right oh yeah
uh dak before he died in the battle of
hoth and stuff all these like really
cool all the rogue squadron characters
what's the one game nobody
of that movie like that game was awesome
so i could do a boost impression do it
can you do subordinate engines though
no that game
ever mentioned any of the
numerous film tie-in games that came out
yeah that series which almost
ubiquitously sucked i'm sure there were
one or two goblins in there
i worked in retail when they brought out
like some of the the yeah the ones for
like the the prequels and they were on
every platform like there was like seven
different versions
what about like disney infinity
it's not star wars game no does it
infinity 3.0 yeah
i mean it's like jack skellington's in
your star wars game
it's like those i don't know i didn't
watch those kids shows but it's kind of
cool if you had a kid be like here play
star wars stuff but yeah not really for
me yeah
it'd be cool to get your kids star wars
toys that aren't like
super nice lego sets that i'm keeping
i like it uh gentlemen thank you coming
up for coming on talking all about star
wars
that film's coming out pretty soon that
game done came out last week uh so to
keep up in touch with all of your hot
star wars video game and film news uh
stay tuned to gamespot.com let us know
in the comments what your favorite star
wars video game is and why we are wrong
all right we'll be back in a second eric
tay is coming on to show us all his
bloodborne gifts but before that here's
a trailer for republique it's the
european trailer
peggy 16.
republic is a campaign-rich experience
where players are center stage and a
multi-layered political thriller
republic started off as sort of a
nostalgic remix of some of our favorite
survival horror games
on playstation one and what it's evolved
into is this fearless take on
story-driven games that you can't find
anywhere else republic is about a woman
named hope trapped inside a secret
totalitarian nation and it's your job to
help her escape republic is not only
about immersing the player in a story
it's about making them a central figure
in the fiction the game takes place in a
secret country called metamorphosis by
connecting to hope's stolen mobile
device players hack into the network of
metamorphosis and guide hope to freedom
so hope and the player are going to
experience many hardships along the way
but for us it was really important to
always bring it back to hope who she is
what's important to her and who she's
becoming along the way at the heart of
the game is a player's relationship with
hope we've built every encounter and
every puzzle around this mechanic after
three years of development we have
readied all five episodes of the game
and we're packaging together in one epic
long-form experience on playstation 4.
so we've spent the better part of the
year reimagine the game to work with the
dualshock 4 controller we've developed a
console friendly ui an all-new cover
system and implemented hundreds of tiny
fixes under the hood to make republic on
ps4 the most seamless experience
possible we put our heart and souls into
the development of republic a game with
an incredible amount of content built
over the span of three years so with
five unique episodes a script as long as
a 400 page novel over 50 tracks of music
and voice over performances from legends
like david hader jennifer hale dwight
schultz republic has been a labor of
love and we just couldn't be more
thrilled to see it all come together in
a complete package on playstation 4.
republic
say a word in french eric tay
bonsoir
sure say a word in french mike mahari
merci yes
all right let's keep going bonjour no no
he goes next oh you could take that one
now you're done got nothing you could
have just taken bonjour whatever could
have said bonjour that's fine you could
say odin
what computer
your
we had a back and forth where we had a
say it in
chinese
and irish
back and forth and i couldn't say milk
couldn't say milk can you see him look
now
yeah i think spanish is the one i know
most aside from english same look in
spanish
video juegos video juegos.com that's a
website that you're not currently
watching nope stay tuned here though
because we're going to talk about video
games in just a second bloodborne came
out earlier this year eric tay mike
mccarty the expansion pack uh the old
blood came out last night
old hunters the old hunters that's
wolfenstein damn it wolfenstein get out
of my brain that game is pretty good but
we're not here to talk about that talk
about the
hard on of god for old yharnam
does that work
first part of the pr especially
you've been playing it since last night
the expansion back i've been playing it
for longer than that oh have you i was
playing it since last night really yeah
he's been at it for like a week now
we'll get to you in a minute okay mike
my hearty yeah eric tell me about these
hunters what's going on uh it so
basically you're kind of like traveling
in a way back or like not back but
you're going into the hunter's nightmare
okay so still in yharnam it's still in
the same it's yeah it's kind of still in
yharnam but it's all like
slightly different it's all like
i think to use miguel's word the
reviewer's word it's like doe-fide okay
so like here you go you can see it here
it's all like oh kind of just
i guess the desert it turned into a
desert whatever um but so so you see
that i'm fighting a hunter there and
basically what's happened is a lot of
these hunters that are in the hunter's
nightmare are just super bloodthirsty
and so they just kill anything on site
so he's way more aggressive then yeah so
you had to deal with a bunch more of
them that you you didn't have to in the
original game as well as other monsters
um but yeah it's it's kind of more
bloodborne
uh it's it's cool i like it there's like
a bunch of new weapons
um yeah what's in it because i think
originally wasn't this this is actually
a makeup of two different dlc packs that
they sort of decided oh actually we're
gonna bundle these together add a bit
more content and make it a yeah so
there's not gonna be another expansion
this is like the only one for bloodborne
and uh i think it's like
over 12
uh primary like right-handed weapons and
then there's like five uh like secondary
weapons which are like you know your gun
there's a gatling gun there's a church
cannon that's uh one of the new weapons
of blood letter is a good variety in
these because obviously one of the
really important things about these
games is that the weapons do like change
the sort of you know cadence and rhythm
of combat yeah there's definitely a wide
variety of weapons you know to suit
different players needs if they want
agility or strength there's a little bit
of more arcane stuff not too much but a
little bit and that's kind of what
bloodborne is about because it's not so
um in-depth in terms of like dark souls
stats you know like that that was a big
thing where
you know you could really tweak a build
you can kind of do it here but not
really it's the weapons that really
change
the [ __ ] is that thing yeah it's so the
amidala arm there
is kind of like those aliens you saw but
it's kind of like a little piece of it
so it's an interesting kind of like
mace type thing that also has like a
like
like a tentacle type thing that's the
saw that they had in that people were
sort of pausing on the trailer as well
yeah and new outfits as well uh yeah
there's uh uh like four or five sets of
new armor there could be more i haven't
like found all the secrets i think
that's one of the cool things about
bloodborne is that even though i beat it
there's all this stuff i'm still finding
and still trying to find um and yeah so
cool stuff though excellent uh mike what
are you thinking about i got to the
first boss and
died on my second try and i got
semi-close when i was talking to t i
know like
i don't want to spoil anything about any
bosses but yeah it's definitely more the
same which i was completely looking for
is looking for an excuse to get back
into it after a new game plus but it
took so long to you have to beat i don't
know what is that like i said
it's totally out there you have to beat
uh vicar emilia this one of these bosses
kind of like early game bosses in order
to get to it and i was oh wow i spent so
long on her
that i by the time i got to the
expansion last night i was just i was
exhausted but i got to the first boss
and uh it definitely it's like he said
like you see way more hunters which are
always pretty
they're pretty formidable yeah and it's
very weird because
so i'm so used to everything from the
first game i played through it uh two
new
i have gamepl a new like area to explore
it's a little more back to how i felt
when i first played bloodborne in the
first place like just way more
unwelcoming i don't know what's around
the next corner it's kind of unsettling
but in a great way so i you know never
played any of the old games there's a
bunch of people here who've got like you
know
lots of love for dark souls demon souls
and then played a bunch of this as well
um i never completed bloodborne but i
adored it like really had a great time
with it is there anything in this for me
or is this very much for people who have
completed bloodborne early in the year
i would say this is mainly for people
who've completed bloodborne i think it's
the first boss i actually have been
i think the first boss here is
one of the more challenging bosses in
like bloodborne itself because there are
a few bosses i could see having as much
trouble with in the main game but
and you could jump into it if you wanted
to if you haven't been the game i would
definitely recommend beating the game
first and maybe starting a new one or
just doing it in new game plus although
the latter is going to be a little
harder i think yeah
and how much how much do you think is in
this one today like in terms of
in you know it's hours yeah kind of yeah
without getting that weird about it but
like yeah it's been like eight months or
whatever since bloodborne came out it
was back in march now so yeah like is
there enough here to get you going for
another couple of weeks or or is it
pretty sure
weeks is kind of a
kind of a stretch i would say i mean
like if you go in if you play it slowly
maybe like weeks uh i would say
for me i've hit in the teens i did
struggle with some of the bosses some
people may some people may not um they
do have like a new system where you can
uh
call on like these co-op ai uh hunters
in the game that you couldn't do in the
past like so in the in the original
version the only way you could really
get help was you had to ring your bell
and hope that somebody i think that was
like 10 levels around you could come and
help you but this time around for maybe
some of the players that you know were
struggling or something like that they
have a way to do that so but it it got
me in the teens in terms of like hours
played and uh there's always little
secrets that depending on how like much
you want to figure them out like they
will add hours to the gameplay that's
what's getting me back into it right now
is like trying to figure out which
weapons are good there's so many weapons
now like the weapons is part of the
replayability of bloodborne because you
can't level them within one playthrough
you can really only level like one
really solidly to max level and then
it's like well i kind of want to try
this other weapon or this other build or
something so it's it's up to the player
at that point um
but yeah i think i think it's it's
pretty solid though uh bloodborne the
old hunters 9 out of 10 on gameswell.com
uh before i let you guys go our gaming
your discussions are ramping up we're
getting almost into december we're going
to be having some real fun chats next
week uh where does bloodborne lie in
here i don't you know a lot of people
aren't saying it's like the best game
that's come out but it's certainly up
there right in the top like 10 at least
for some of the best games that have
come out this year yeah i think uh i'll
just go first but like i think for both
of us personally i think personally for
both of us i think it's within our top
ten for this year i never played five
i don't know i was actually like
messing around with the list a little
bit this morning and it might be for me
um i never played a souls game i was
always kind of afraid it was something
that looked kind of like a huge time
scene something that could frustrate the
hell out of me
and i'm just somebody who plays a lot of
like diablo yeah yeah i get into
grinding games and stuff like that but
like
i don't know what it was about
bloodborne that drew me to it it just
seemed like oh this is kind of like dark
souls was like way faster and more
action oriented and
i just love the combat like you feel
rewarded
when you do something really like
amazing you perfect dodge or like when
you wait and you learn the moves and the
subtle nuances and you're like okay he's
gonna do this bang shoot you with the
gun stick my arm through your chest and
you just feel good like when you do that
and that's what bloodborne gave for me
and
you know i it was frustrating at times
but i knew why i died like it was like a
mistake i if i
like panic dodged or like was spamming
dodge too much i would get hit and it's
like yup i totally deserve that and
there's something about
that that kind of game that just drew me
in and probably in my top five it's cool
tough but fair mike what about yourself
yeah i definitely put in my top five um
i i've been playing it throughout the
year still with new game plus and kind
of one of those games i've been going
back to throughout the year and like tay
said the combat is satisfying you always
feel like it was your fault it would
unlike the dark souls games which a lot
of times can kind of throw these
curveballs at you it always felt like it
was really you could master it and get
through it and also i think the level
design itself is just unreal between
just finding a new lantern and a
shortcut is as much a victory almost a
lot of times like maybe not as much as
killing a boss but it's up there cool
gentlemen thank you so much for coming
on yeah bloodborne the old hunters uh
out now if you're a bloodborne fan go
pick it up let us know what you think of
it and bloodborne's chance at game of
the year in the comment box below
all right that was a bumper ass
[ __ ] video game show right
there
guys thanks so much for coming on
chatting to us
yeah giveaway giveaway got it man
screaming from the back i had your back
mary just want you to know
i can't even i thought we were talking
about a wolfenstein expansion this whole
time
don't even get me started on the
giveaways uh we got a giveaway sick
these look familiar these look familiar
oh yeah we uh me and andy got these at
the
overwatch preview event back in
month like two months ago or something
in the course man these are these are
the hot the hot pictures
there's a lot of
twitch streamers taking photographs of
them
about their free gifts
halo yeah is it halo yeah all right cool
yo kish
look at this thing follow and retweet at
gamespot for a chance to win overwatch
hitti and the halo darker is this the
same one that chris had in that video
yeah just show her that i'm gonna open
it better i'm gonna open it
i'm gonna open it oh yeah dart gun
battle pack i shouldn't open it because
it's got plastic on it is it right here
i think that's the little you got it
right here
man they uh
they really closed this thing up but
this one she'll give this way without
showing it we don't have a picture of
the dark gun
i mean
you might want this stock gun
tay's gonna open it am i okay i can
totally do that uh sorry to whoever wins
this i think this one's already been
taken off did you think i think
oh i heard it open really
chris did a video on the needler which
i'm not sure if that's what this is you
can't do it you can't do it this way
how many
minutes will it take to open a box do
you have that tear this thing apart is
that what's gonna happen
you could do it show's already too long
let's keep going
i'm not being too helpful mike you're
giving us oh here we go it opens in a
weird way it's an unorthodox board
it did this
oh it was over on this side stupid
those are awesome i can see oh hey hello
look at that [ __ ] unsc m6 blaster
covenant plasma overcharge
blaster
blaster is what you say when you want to
sell a gun to kids but don't want to
call it gun check them out
halo boomco slide action eric tay yeah
look at that get one for you and your
buddy go
dual wielding on your on your on your
friends and your enemies and your
frenemies dude i want this covenant
carbine blaster imagine doing that
wearing an overwatch hoodie you confuse
everyone
brandalism
yeah that's all right the kids don't
kids don't care they don't care not all
in snapchat that's the halo one
do you like that perfect you like that
one
there it is eric tay is endorsing it
there you go
taste bash
halo tay this isn't destiny this isn't
that no it's not
where's the uh destiny hawkmoon
this is destiny you'd have to these
would blow up every time you use them
you have to pay ten dollars for more
than a nice sweater it's a snap like
there's snap buttons and a hood i know
it's it's legit
if you want to look like you're from
overwatch university you get yourself
that that one's a medium you feel like
this is what like the overwatch
university
marching band would wear yeah exactly do
you want to be part of
owu
yeah follow gamespot on twitter and
retweet that thing
mike mccarty eric tay thank you so much
for modeling all of our giveaways today
thanks to everyone in the back mary cash
josh joshua damahoric eric tay you're
not back there what's going on i don't
know sometimes we're up here sometimes
we're up here that's how we roll we're
done this week on the lobby we'll be
back next week it's our final lobby on
this set next week and we're also
recording a bunch of hot game of the
year stuff next week as well so stay
tuned for that but we'll be back same
bat time tuesday 2pm pacific right here
on gamespot.com see you then
you